[Music]
in face the consequences news I don't
have that consequences submitted by
mother Joe Malian also many citizens oh
look it's a former Olympian turned
himself into the police after confessing
he stole millions of dollars from
investors and a pyramid scheme why did
he hell on himself he's a [ __ ] rat
where'd you get that [ __ ] s mm whip
from I don't know oh oh it's actually uh
Casey brought it
how do you guys use it Casey's gift you
soon no he bought it as a prop for waxes
music video oh yeah yeah yeah don'tdon't
again you guys ain't into that stuff no
I'm not either
sorry I'm not either
alright so how did he steal millions
what kind of Limpy it is he a bobsledder
or a shop litter shark all of our fast
Walker yeah man that wasn't even a
hard-working pump player bit I didn't
ask ping-pong player who does he so
there is about Harold Becker he's 63
years old from Canada he was a former
Olympic rower Oh turned into businessman
one of the unimportant sports so he he
took part in three Olympics in 88 and 84
88 and 92 I mean he was hella good yeah
you did three that's a long career where
he gold medalist he never won a medal
I'm Canada then always [ __ ] and you're
the joke yeah it wouldn't like well for
the rest of you that Harris I love
Canada I love Canada by the way we all
again I don't represent geo spots this
is all Geo not JK let's go ahead sick
are you gonna say something about Jenna
hundred percent but it's not a Bobby J
keg disclaimer this is not my joke I'm
not that clever but a comedian a very
famous comedian said it would be so cool
to see the average person go against an
Olympian and then you said alway but
that's what Candis is therefore
I mean you can about that clever [ __ ]
up joke - you know cuz a lot of a lot of
countries a little when you call me -
you wouldn't even make it on the Olympic
team of America they're just not on that
level well we're not a lot of countries
a country like you know a battery set it
back in the day they took her arm they
took a college basketball team from the
US and they won gold medal they smashed
all the Olympic basketball players
because they don't have the hip-hop it's
just the sport of being on the same
level don't have the hip hop y'all going
to face black people but I was like wait
there's a lot of black people in Africa
they got but see that they got African
people we have black people those are
two different that's why I said but what
makes the black people here different
for the African people they invented
hip-hop here we got the hip-hop which
makes the basketball better
we got the Jazz give me the scoop about
Bobby Bell so basketball like that that
attitude instead of like what kind of it
was haha 11
so anyways Harold he launched a mutual
fund investment company in Canada back
in 1996 and so he had a lot of his
friends and former coaches and former
teammates as a part of his clients and
so that's a former teammate oh you
[ __ ] up your homies below yeah damn
that's like a [ __ ] street no no he
was investing his friends retirement
fund all capital oh good and so when
there when the dot-com crash hit in late
90s he said that his fund lost 25 to 45
percent of their market value
and so what he tried to do he didn't
tell anyone that this happened he tried
to recover the losses by using one
person's cash to cover another's in a
pyramid scheme so like that's how he was
trying to cover it's full-time so candid
of disappearing back in November 2015 he
was last seen on surveillance footage
disembarking a ferry in a port in
Washington State and so he had camping
gear and a passport he told his family
he was going to be going on a bicycle
ride when he disappeared he left his
phone at home to avoid detection he was
gone for a year and a half and so what a
long bicycle ride he's all got his
little helmet on yes just ended up
working like a police hunt in Canada and
in the u.s. oh because we're friendly so
it's like hey we're practically the same
country but they're like The Forgotten
brother yes I mean here's a picture of
him look like a nice guy he got that
con-artist smile though again we're
telling ya don't trust anybody with thin
lips yeah you big lips can't tell a lie
you must be the most honest person on
earth God I can't it just it just rolls
out but then lips yes sir that's the UH
taking first oh that's Korean a white
person things that there's nothing to it
right yeah yeah you think white people
have to know if it looks like it says so
years riding a bike someone you were
right Joe so what ended up happening is
his family and friends they launched a
Facebook appeal call and they labeled it
a finding Harold Becker and so they were
just sharing like a lot of their pleas
like trying to get any information on
where he went and hoping that he would
come back including one of his teammates
that he lost 800,000 oh my god
go online that's why you never trust
people huh will you trust us I know okay
I just wanted I just wanted to say that
because people always say that you know
people always go like that's why you
don't do business with friends and
family they'll [ __ ] you over I just
wanted to I just wanted to say what
everyone else is always great thing
about doing business with friends and
families without reality it's tell them
oh [ __ ] you up yeah [ __ ] you up you
can't do that to just a regular random
person now they're gonna see exactly but
to a family member is like they'll call
the police
ah man would you hand on the shoulder
like this and you wear it really tight
and you're hey do your [ __ ] job will
[ __ ] you up everyday to do so nice
beautiful that's poetry to my ears
or you could just give us your shirt
welcome that's that's so there's so much
love in that statement hmm maybe I
concur wanna talk [ __ ] yeah you guys
make sure you [ __ ] call your parents
yep you tell on them oh that's the
different you look at the grip on their
shoulder you say hey I'm gonna call you
do this you're just strangers and
there's this like business thing you
don't get to know their parents and you
can't tell their parents anything how do
you hurt somebody tell the [ __ ] mom
yeah mom's are not only I'm not gonna
beat you up but you know what
i'ma tell on you there's clearly sleep
you say that to a 50 year old man you'll
be like no he's not not not my mom see I
know she calls you up go business with
strangers they'll [ __ ] have lawyers
we'll have all this [ __ ] but family and
friends have mom rat you could tell
their mom and their mom will call them
every [ __ ] day and make them feel
like [ __ ] yeah so that's a difference do
business with friends and family yeah
reasons why you should you got contact
with them all that's all you need
so what happened now you turn himself in
and is it going to jail we're glad you
did was he disrespected I know I thought
you wanted our attention or something
ladies and gentlemen I present
Giavanna come on okay what do you say
cuz you just interrupted the whole
conversation what is so [ __ ]
important
is nice lemon okay you have a ban on
health after baby slamming away so he
turned himself in he walked into the
police station I know why he did it
why because they were holding his family
ransom oh hey come back here we're gonna
shake your family obvious all the
Canadians are violent at that though I
think they're a lot more logical and
smart but when it comes to money people
change
yeah but he's Canadian - in US I think
after five years he decided well how
many years it's been a year and a half
yep after that he goes my Canadian DNA
tells me that I cannot live with his
guilt so I must be the Honourable
Canadian well I didn't even get a chance
to mention the fact that he he actually
wrote letters to all these people that I
got affected by his business
vasawi so he said yeah human beings are
and he was just saying like that his 1.5
million dollar life insurance policy was
enough to reimburse everyone falou
thinking something about killing himself
I don't know is that wasn't stated but I
guess I can assume that and but the
clients that lost their money they said
nobody that's about half you always
three million so that terms of twice so
then you estimate maybe two bullets
instead of one it's got a full of true
the price really fast
well you'd want to die but people say oh
he's crazy
how'd you do that bro I am hard you
always hate to be that detective I gotta
figure the situation up it really he
didn't even have a right to know this
Hannity but anyways out yes I did she
was so pulled up now you owe me twice
[ __ ] but um hands up eggs and the
letters cost I am truly sorry for the
effects of my poor decisions my
investors have been my friend and I have
done a terrible thing to my friends my
choice at this point is to do anything
in my power to cover the investment
losses I have created
yes admitting to fraud would help resort
the losses I would accept the criminal
penalty a does everything I'm sorry
Canada we love you what is the penalty
they know Gmail faces two counts of
fraud worth more than $5,000
hey and have nothing to appear in court
so that's pretty much the story of
Harold Becker hello Marta people do you
want to contact me and everybody else
you see go ahead and check the
description box below and follow our
social media is the grants and Twitter's
for more videos click up there baby
[Music]